welcome to Takei's take a new show about
what I know best the Internet
you may know me from Facebook now I'm
trying out YouTube oh my Takei's take is
a new YouTube show starring George Takei
from the original Star Trek as well as
one of my favorite anchors from the
Howard Stern Show it's a show with a
comedic look at technology there's going
to be a lot of famous guests and you can
hear his opinion on all of the things
involving the internet if you would like
to subscribe the annotation is right
there let them know the Chris Duckman
sent you over thanks guys
[Music]
so if you haven't noticed the
backgrounds a little different there are
some things that are the same there are
some things that are different I haven't
finished it yet though this is only
about halfway done I just recently moved
to a new condominium and this is my
current background it's not completely
done there will be new things added in
the future but for now let's talk about
a brand new video game that I've played
recently called beyond 2 souls the plot
of this game revolves around a girl who
was born with a supernatural entity
attached to her called item this thing
can interact with the environment
oftentimes it protects Jody from danger
but it also is a hardship for her
because it causes a lot of problems for
her sometimes she just wants to have a
normal life but this thing constantly is
interacting with her and with the
environment sometimes she's picked on by
a bully or something and this thing
tries to protect her and she becomes
known as a freak as a young kid and it
makes it very difficult for her to have
a normal life with this thing always
literally hovering over her that can
interact with the environment it's the
kind of game where you are given almost
like a choose-your-own-adventure type of
feel it's kind of like those books from
the 90s where you could read a chapter
pick a way to go and you might end up
dead on the next page if you do it
incorrectly this game is very much like
that where you have various options of
what to pick for certain things you
could do as your main character Jodi
this character is actually voiced and
acted and modeled by Ellen Page which is
really cool because that's a rarity in
games where a famous actress or actor
will be like yeah I'll model this
usually it's people that are
specifically in the field of video game
acting but this game actually has Ellen
Page and Willem Dafoe you are given the
opportunity to be eyed in many times
throughout this game a lot of times you
can actually take revenge on people that
perhaps bullied her or save her from a
situation or even like grab a helicopter
that's in midair and just throw it into
a building it's pretty awesome one of
the things I've noticed about this game
is that some people are a little bit
mixed over it and I think it really
boils down to what type of gamer you are
as you guys know I'm a huge movie fan I
love movies and so this game
is more for me if you're just a strict
gamer you're not a fan of cutscenes you
just want to control a character and
play a game and not really have that
movie type feel this game might not be
for you it's very much in the same vein
as heavy rain very similar control
scheme and in that way some people may
not enjoy this game as much as others I
however since I am a huge movie fan
loved this game I found it to be deeply
involving it had a very interesting
character and I like the way the story
was actually told through a nonlinear
structure in that way you can sort of
piece the story together as the game
allows you to take it in and that's one
of the things that's so cool about this
game is that it's not just a very well
made game with excellent graphics and
really good gameplay and a cool twist on
how you can control a person's thoughts
and reactions it's a focus on story
which is really cool because most games
just like hey shoot them all kill them
all blow everything up and sometimes
that can be fun to just have a game
that's just kind of mindless fun like
that but this game is so focused on
character and story that I really found
myself much more attached to the
characters in this game than I usually
am in a video game with the lack of us
coming out this year games now have a
whole other playing field to operate on
when it comes to character models
because that game was so realistic and
that was the best acting I'd ever seen
in a video game this game is terrific as
well in that regard it's not quite on
the same powers last of us the graphics
are so impressive the character models
are beautiful and the acting is very
good but I would say the last of us is
just graphically a little bit better but
possibly the acting is even better in
this game because you care so much about
this character and Ellen Page did such a
good job to portray this tortured person
you see where other games have such a
focus on trying to complete various
missions and tasks and trying to do this
and do that and here's your objectives
here's your checkpoints what this game
is is it's a game that allows you to
feel as if you are in the world that
this game is portraying and it's a game
that is so good
and making you feel as if you are this
character like in a game sometimes you
can die over and over and over again
you're like oh crap I died in this game
if you die you just die like you are
literally given the option to commit
suicide throughout this game because she
is so torch
as a character I don't even know what
would happen if I had chosen that round
I didn't because I was like the game
might actually end I don't know cuz
David cage the creator of this game in
the crater of heavy rain is a very
twisted guy I can tell cause like
there's literally a scene where you like
you have a knife you're like you can cut
your wrists now if you want it I think I
don't I don't know about this one but I
gotta give this game props for being so
emotionally involving and being a game
that I found myself so attached to that
I had to keep going back and playing
video games are now at a point where it
has transcended beep well that was I
guess that was video games back in the
day I don't know what I'm saying is
video games are really seriously an art
form now and this game proves it I'm
going to give beyond two souls and nine
out of ten so guys I hope you do get a
chance to play this game and like I said
this background isn't completely done
I'm not finished yet it will be soon
though but thanks as always for watching
guys and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]